Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
DEAN, URIJAH,
SHOW THEM WHAT WE GOT!
BOOM!
OOH.
I HAD THIS LIGHT-BULB MOMENT.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA,
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
WHAT IF I VALUED IT
AT $6 MILLION?
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'M NOTED FOR MY CREATIVITY.
THE OTHER GUYS ARE BRAIN-DEAD.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
NEVER HAVE I HEARD SOMEBODY
TALK SO MUCH AND SAY SO LITTLE.
HOLD ON!
LET ME FINISH.
GET IT OUT!
WHAT IS IT?!
IT'S GONNA GET REALLY UGLY
IN A MINUTE.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS A UNIQUE
WAY TO ILLUMINATE YOUR LIFE.
MY NAME IS MAX.
I'M THE FOUNDER AND CREATOR
OF LUMIO.
TODAY I'M SEEKING $250,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 8% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
LUMIO.
IT'S AN ELEGANT
LIGHTING SOLUTION
THAT GIVES YOU THE FREEDOM
TO EXPERIENCE BEAUTIFUL LIGHTING
WHEREVER YOU ARE.
OH, WOW.
PRETTY COOL.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOME OF THE WAYS
YOU CAN USE LUMIO.
OPEN IT AND IT CREATES
A NICE AMBIENT LIGHT.
YOU CAN OPEN IT
ALL THE WAY, 360.
OR USE IT
AS DIRECTIONAL TASK LIGHTING
TO READ OR WRITE.
AND IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE UNITS,
YOU CAN COMBINE THEM TOGETHER.
THIS FIXTURE INSIDE
HAS SUPERSTRONG MAGNETS,
SO YOU CAN CONFIGURE THIS
INTO MANY DIFFERENT FORMS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THAT'S REALLY COOL.
SO BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
YOU CAN ALSO USE IT
ON ANY VERTICAL SURFACES.
IT JUST HAS TO GO
TO METAL.
CORRECT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT,
THE BEST WAY TO EXPERIENCE
AND UNDERSTAND THE PRODUCT
IS FOR YOU TO REALLY HOLD IT
IN YOUR HANDS.
YEAH.
I BROUGHT A FEW SAMPLES
WITH ME.
HERE YOU GO, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
OH!
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, THAT'S SO COOL!
SO, MAX, IT'S OBVIOUSLY
BATTERY-OPERATED.
HOW LONG
DO THE BATTERIES LAST FOR?
EIGHT HOURS,
AND THAT'S THE WHOLE IDEA.
I DON'T WANT TO JUST DESIGN
SOMETHING BEAUTIFUL.
I WANT IT FUNCTIONAL.
SO EIGHT HOURS IS ENOUGH POWER
TO LAST YOU OVERNIGHT.
IT'S RECHARGEABLE
THROUGH MICRO USB.
IT TAKES
ABOUT THREE TO FOUR HOURS
TO GET THE FULL CAPACITY
OF EIGHT HOURS.
John: THIS IS COOL.
SO, MAX, IT BRINGS A SMILE
TO YOUR FACE WHEN YOU OPEN IT.
TELL ME YOUR VISION
BEHIND THE APPLICATION OF IT.
THIS IS A LIGHTING SOLUTION
THAT YOU CAN USE
AROUND THE HOUSE
FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER,
BUT ALSO, I THINK
OUTDOOR MARKET IS HUGE.
WE LAUNCHED JUST LAST YEAR.
WE DID $1 MILLION WITHOUT
ANY ADVERTISING, MARKETING.
$1 MILLION?
CORRECT.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
WE GOT CLOSE TO $580,000
ON KICKSTARTER.
WOW.
WHAT WAS YOUR GOAL?
$60,000.
WHAT DO YOU
SELL THEM FOR?
CURRENTLY,
WE'RE SELLING $190 PER UNIT.
$190?
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE?
RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE AT $65.
DAYMOND, FIRST YEAR,
OUR COST OF GOODS WAS $80.
IN THE PAST THREE MONTHS,
WE ARE ABLE
TO LOWER IT DOWN TO $65.
I LIVED IN THE FACTORY
FOR FOUR MONTHS.
WHAT COUNTRY?
I HAD TO GO TO CHINA.
SO THAT YOU COULD
WATCH THE PROCESS
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO IMPROVE IT?
EXACTLY.
IT LOOKS SIMPLE, BUT IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE DETAILING.
YOU BELIEVE YOU CAN GET
THAT $65 PRICE WAY DOWN?
CORRECT.
TO WHAT?
YEAH, TO WHAT?
THE IDEAL FOR ME IS $50,
WHICH IS 33% OF REVENUE.
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING
MOST OF THESE?
MUSEUM OF MODERN ART
IN NEW YORK,
MOCA IN L.A., SFMOMA,
COOPER HEWITT,
AND WE DO HAVE
AN E-COMMERCE,
AND THAT'S ALSO
40% OF THE SALES.
RIGHT NOW,
PART OF THE PAIN POINT
IS WE CANNOT KEEP UP
WITH DEMAND.
OKAY, SO, YOU'RE LIMITING
YOUR DISTRIBUTION
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH DEMAND.
EXACTLY.
O'Leary: WHAT ABOUT
LIGHTING DISTRIBUTORS?
ANYBODY APPROACH YOU AND SAY,
"LOOK, I WANT TO SUPPORT
THE 10,000 LIGHTING STORES
IN AMERICA"?
THEY HAVE APPROACHED ME,
BUT HERE'S MY VISION --
I WANT TO BUILD A BRAND.
THIS YEAR, THE FOCUS
IS TO PARTNER WITH GREAT BRANDS.
I FOCUS ON
THE BRAND-BUILDING COMPANIES
THAT I WANT TO WORK WITH.
WHAT STORES IN THE U.S.
WOULD YOU ACTUALLY SELL IT?
GIVE ME SOME BRANDS
OUTSIDE OF THE MUSEUM STORES.
I THINK DESIGN WITHIN REACH
WOULD BE A GREAT FIT.
BUT ARE YOU PLANNING
ON EXPANDING
INTO A BROADER BASE
OF RETAILERS?
I'M LOOKING INTO THAT
NEXT YEAR.
YOU KNOW,
YOU CANNOT BE TOO GREEDY,
AND I DON'T WANT TO DILUTE
THE BRAND.
ARE YOU SAYING TO KEVIN,
"YOU CANNOT BE TOO GREEDY"?
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban: MAX, KEEP ON TELLING US
ABOUT YOUR VISION.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT FOLLOWS THIS. WHAT'S NEXT?
SO, I'VE CREATED
THIS PROTOTYPE.
SO, IT'S A MINI VERSION.
John: MM!
Cuban: WOW.
Herjavec: WOW!
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN ASKED
BY OUR DISTRIBUTOR IN JAPAN,
AND THEY SAY,
"EVERYONE IS ASKING
Greiner: CAN I SEE IT?
ABOUT THE MINI VERSION."
SO, IT'S A LITTLE
NIGHT-LIGHT.
CORRECT.
SO, IF THIS IS
MORE FOR USE AROUND THE HOUSE,
I WANT THIS
TO LIVE IN YOUR BAG.
AND THESE DAYS,
EVERYONE WHO IS MOBILE,
YOU'RE ALWAYS
RUNNING OUT OF JUICE.
NOW,
THIS HAS THE CAPABILITY
FOR YOU TO RECHARGE
ALL YOUR MOBILE DEVICES.
O'Leary:
SO, THIS YEAR'S SALES,
IF EVERYTHING KEEPS GOING
WITH YOUR CONTROLLED CHANNELS,
HAVE YOU ESTIMATED
WHAT YOUR SALES WILL BE?
YES -- CONSERVATIVE, $2 MILLION.
$2.5, VERY DOABLE.
AND WHAT WILL YOU MAKE ON THAT,
DO YOU THINK
15%.
I MEAN,
I THINK THIS WOULD BE GREAT
IN THE SLS OR THE W's ROOMS,
AND PEOPLE CAN TAKE THEM.
EXACTLY. I'M STEPPING --
INCHING TOWARDS THAT.
Herjavec:
I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
EVERY TIME WE OPEN IT,
IT BROUGHT A SMILE TO MY FACE.
I THINK YOU'RE
REALLY ONTO SOMETHING.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
YOU'RE AN INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSIVE GUY.
YOU WENT TO THE FACTORY.
I DON'T THINK WE EVER HAD
ANYBODY COME OUT HERE
AND SAY,
"I GOT A FACTORY IN CHINA,
AND I WENT AND LIVED THERE
FOR FOUR MONTHS."
AND I KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE,
AND THAT WAS NOT EASY.
IT'S NOT EASY.
SO, MAX, LET ME START.
YEP.
I SHARE YOUR VISION. I THINK
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
AND I THINK YOUR VALUATION
IS PRETTY FAIR.
$250,000 FOR 10%.
SO, ROBERT, I LOVE YOU.
THANK YOU. [ LAUGHS ]
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
UM, WOULD YOU MIND
IF I ASKED THE OTHER SHARKS
TO SEE
IF THEY ARE INTERESTED,
JUST TO SEE
WHAT THEIR OFFERS ARE?
I'M INTERESTED,
AND I'M GONNA STRUCTURE
A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY, OKAY?
HE'S GONNA DO A ROYALTY DEAL.
IT'S SHOCKING, I KNOW.
HERE COMES
THE BLOODSUCKING OFFER.
I'M GONNA HELP YOU,
BECAUSE YOU'RE BASICALLY VALUING
YOUR BUSINESS AT $3.1 MILLION.
WHAT IF I VALUED IT
AT $6 MILLION?
WHOA.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN.
MAX HAS AN OFFER FROM ROBERT
FOR $250,000
FOR 10% OF HIS INNOVATIVE
LIGHTING COMPANY, LUMIO.
BUT KEVIN
SURPRISINGLY SUGGESTS
A HIGHER VALUATION
FOR THE COMPANY.
YOU'RE BASICALLY VALUING
YOUR BUSINESS AT $3.1 MILLION.
WHAT IF I VALUED IT
AT $6 MILLION?
WHOA.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
THE $250,000,
AND YOU'RE GONNA PAY IT BACK
TO ME UNTIL I DOUBLE MY MONEY.
YOU'LL PAY ME $7 A UNIT
UNTIL I GET $500,000 BACK.
THEN THAT GOES AWAY
IN PERPETUITY. IT'S GONE.
AND I'LL HAVE A 4% OWNERSHIP
IN THE COMPANY
FOR PROVIDING THAT,
AND, OF COURSE, I'LL HELP YOU
FINANCE YOUR PURCHASE ORDERS.
THE KEY TO MY OFFER
IS THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
WITH A $6.2 MILLION VALUATION.
AND I'VE REFLECTED
IN MY STRUCTURE --
AND I'M NOTED
FOR MY CREATIVITY.
THE OTHER GUYS
ARE BRAIN-DEAD HERE.
THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS.
IT'S, UM, THANK YOU --
MAX, WHEN THIS SHOW AIRS,
RIGHT,
THERE'S GONNA BE
AN AMAZING AMOUNT
OF DEMAND
FOR THE PRODUCT.
IS SELLING FROM YOUR WEBSITE
TO "SHARK TANK" VIEWERS
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE INVENTORY
TO DO?
E-COMMERCE IS
NUMBER-ONE PRIORITY
BECAUSE THE MARGIN
IS THE HIGHEST.
Herjavec: I AGREE.
OKAY, SO, YOU WANT TO MAXIMIZE
THE NUMBERS THERE.
EXACTLY.
BECAUSE YOU TAKE THE STRATEGY
MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS.
RIGHT, MARK.
OKAY, I'LL MAKE YOU
AN OFFER, THEN,
BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED TO KNOW.
OH, SHARK FIGHT.
SHARK FIGHT. SHARK FIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S MY STRENGTH,
IS E-COMMERCE,
AND, OBVIOUSLY,
BUILDING YOUR BRAND,
YOU'RE DOING IT
THE EXACT RIGHT WAY.
THE PRODUCT
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF,
AND IT'S AN APPROACH
THAT I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH.
I'LL OFFER YOU $500,000
FOR 16%.
THAT GIVES YOU CAPITAL TO GROW
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT BEING DEAD
ON YOUR BALANCE SHEET,
AND IT GIVES ME
ENOUGH SKIN IN THE GAME.
IT GIVES YOU CAPITAL TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH INVENTORY,
'CAUSE I THINK
THIS WILL SELL VERY WELL.
SO, THAT'S MY OFFER --
$500,000 FOR 16%.
VERY GENEROUS OFFER.
I ALWAYS LOVE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES, RIGHT?
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
YOU GROW STRONGER.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
WANT TO HEAR IT?
OF COURSE. SO...
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU $250,000
FOR 12%
PLUS A $250,000
LINE OF CREDIT.
I LIKE YOUR WHOLE PLAN
WITH THE MUSEUMS.
I SEE THAT
AS YOUR BIG PLAY.
I ALSO SEE THESE BEAUTIFUL
IN COLORS.
SO, I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU
TO CONTINUE
THE PLAN THAT YOU HAVE
AND THEN TO WORK TOGETHER
NEXT GENERATIONS.
I'M GONNA ALSO
GIVE YOU AN OFFER.
THIS IS
KIND OF IN MY SPACE
FOR THE LICENSING
AND FOR THE DISTRIBUTION IN R&D.
SO, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
AN OFFER OF $750,000 FOR 20%,
AND I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO LICENSE IT WITH YOU.
AND WE CAN START OFF WITH
A $10 MILLION LINE OF CREDIT.
INTERESTING.
DAYMOND,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT IS
VERY, VERY GENEROUS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REMARKABLE, MAX.
YOU HAVE FIVE OFFERS.
I ACTUALLY GAVE YOU THE HIGHEST
VALUATION OF ANYBODY.
IN MY OFFER -- THE ONLY ONE
THAT GIVES YOU A $6.2 --
AT LEAST YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
AT A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL
TO FINANCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SELL IT.
YOU DON'T NEED TO FINANCE AGAIN
WITH MY OFFER, THOUGH.
BUT HE WANTS
20% OF YOUR COMPANY.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU WANT ME TO GET UP
AND GO TO WORK.
I DON'T NEED
TO DO THAT.
THERE'S ONLY TWO --
IN THIS CASE,
THERE'S ONLY TWO SHARKS, REALLY,
THAT EAT, SLEEP PRODUCT
EVERY DAY.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YES, IT IS.
NOT AT ALL.
KEVIN, YOU'RE RAISING VENTURE
AROUND THE WORLD.
YOU'RE NOT
PRODUCT-ORIENTATED.
THIS IS NOT
A VENTURE DEAL.
THIS IS ACTUALLY HELPING YOU
FINANCE YOUR GROWTH.
I KNOW IT'S NOT A VENTURE DEAL.
THAT'S MY POINT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE.
NO, BUT HE WANTS
SOMEBODY TO DO R&D.
HE WANTS SOMEBODY OUT THERE
WHO'S GONNA GO WITH HIM
HAND-IN-HAND
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
SO, LET'S SUMMARIZE
WHAT WE HAVE ON THE TABLE.
ROBERT IS 10%
FOR $250,000.
I'M SAYING
I'LL DO 4% OF THE EQUITY.
I'M VALUATING YOUR BUSINESS
THE HIGHEST, AT $6.2 MILLION.
DAYMOND IS REALLY STEPPING UP
HERE, AT $750,000 FOR 20%,
PLUS $10 MILLION
OF CREDIT.
VERY INTERESTING.
MARK IS AT 16% --
SAME VALUE YOU CAME IN WITH.
HE'S JUST DOUBLING
THE OFFER.
GIVING YOU $500,000
FOR 16%.
LORI, WHAT'S YOUR OFFER?
$250,000 FOR 12%
AND A $250,000 LINE OF CREDIT.
Herjavec: MAX, EITHER WAY,
YOU'VE GOT FIVE OFFERS HERE.
THIS IS
YOUR DECISION NOW, MAX.
HOW MUCH OF THE COMPANY
DO YOU WANT TO PART WITH?
WHICH SHARK
DO YOU WANT TO WORK WITH?
MAKE A DECISION.
I'LL SLIGHTLY MODIFY
MY OFFER.
I SHARE YOUR VISION.
I DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE GOING
DOWN THE RIGHT PATH.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD GIVE UP
THAT MUCH EQUITY.
I'LL CHANGE
FROM $250,000 FOR 10%
TO $350,000 FOR 10%.
SLIGHTLY MORE CASH,
BUT AT THE SAME EQUITY LEVEL.
ROBERT, YOU GOT A DEAL.
THANK YOU.
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
SO EXCITED!
ME TOO. ME TOO.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WOW!
I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA DO GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATS, MAX.
CONGRATS.
THANK YOU.
IT'S VERY COOL.
DOESN'T IT MAKE YOU SMILE
EVERY TIME YOU OPEN IT?
YEAH, IT DOES.
IT'S LIKE SUNSHINE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Gunawan:
OH, MY GOSH. I CAN'T BELIEVE
ALL FIVE SHARKS MADE AN OFFER.
AND I'M VERY, VERY EXCITED,
ESPECIALLY TO WORK WITH ROBERT.
HE'S A GREAT GUY.
SO, HE'S EXACTLY
WHO I WANTED TO PARTNER WITH,
AND I GOT A GREAT DEAL FROM HIM,
SO I'M VERY EXCITED.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
ERIN BICKLEY AND JENNY GREER
MADE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA AND LORI
FOR THEIR WOMEN'S SHAPEWEAR
PROJECT, HOLD YOUR HAUNCHES.
I'M OUT.
EVERY TIME THERE'S
A FEMALE PRODUCT ON THIS SHOW,
YOU GUYS GO OUT
RIGHT AWAY.
Greiner: I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
AN OFFER WITH BARB
JUST SO THAT WE CAN SHOW
OUR MALE SHARKS
ABSOLUTELY.
HOW THEY MISSED OUT
ON ONE OF THE BIGGEST SELLERS
OF THIS SEASON.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Greer: IN THE YEAR
LEADING UP TO "SHARK TANK,"
WE ONLY HAD
$165,000 IN SALES.
ERIN, LOOK!
IT'S ONLY BEEN
SIX MONTHS,
AND WE'RE ALREADY
AT $1.5 MILLION IN SALES.
WITH THE SPIKE
IN OUR BUSINESS,
WE WERE ABLE TO MOVE OUT
OF ERIN'S PLAYROOM
AND INTO
THIS WONDERFUL NEW OFFICE,
WHERE WE DO
ALL OF OUR OWN SHIPPING
AND WAREHOUSE
ALL OF OUR PRODUCT.
WHEN WE WERE
IN THE TANK,
MARK, KEVIN, AND ROBERT
DROPPED OUT
BEFORE THEY HEARD
ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
WE BET WE KNOW
WHO'S REGRETTING THAT NOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
GEORGIA NATIONAL FAIR RECOGNIZES
JENNY GREER AND ERIN BICKLEY.
Bickley: OUR BUSINESS
HAS BEEN SUCH A SUCCESS
THAT HERE WE ARE
AT THE GEORGIA NATIONAL FAIR,
RECEIVING
THE GEORGIA GROWN AWARD.
WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME OUR FAVORITE SHARKS,
LORI AND BARBARA!
Corcoran: I AM SO PROUD
OF JENNY AND ERIN
BECAUSE THEY ARE
A WALKING, TALKING EXAMPLE
OF WHAT WOMEN CAN DO
IN AMERICA.
THE GUYS
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN THEM,
BUT THESE TWO SMART WOMEN
BOUGHT IN,
AND NOW LOOK AT THEM.
SORRY, BOYS.
Greer: THANK YOU, LORI GREINER
AND BARBARA CORCORAN.
WE'RE SO APPRECIATIVE
OF ALL YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS IS THE FIRST DEAL
BARBARA AND I HAVE EVER MADE
TOGETHER IN THE TANK.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT WAS A DREAM.
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE
$1.5 MILLION IN SALES,
AND THAT'S
JUST IN SIX MONTHS.
IMAGINE WHAT THEY'LL DO
IN SIX YEARS!
WHY DON'T WE GO SEE THE FAIR?
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
WE ARE SO DELIGHTED
THAT BARBARA AND LORI
GOT BEHIND OUR COMPANY,
'CAUSE NOW THE FOUR OF US
ARE MAKING BEHINDS
LOOK AMAZING EVERYWHERE.
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE A SOLUTION
TO A CHRONIC PROBLEM.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS NEIL,
CO-FOUNDER OF THE NAPWELL.
WE'RE BASED
IN SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA,
AND ARE SEEKING $100,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
THIS IS JUSTIN.
HE'S WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL
A SLEEP ZOMBIE.
[ YAWNS ]
MAYBE
YOU'VE MET HIM BEFORE.
HE'S ON THE SUBWAY,
IN THE LINE AT THE COFFEE SHOP,
AND THE ONE THAT YOU HONK AT
DURING YOUR MORNING COMMUTE.
IN THE U.S.,
TWO OUT OF EVERY FIVE PEOPLE
ARE SLEEP ZOMBIES.
FOR THOSE OF US THAT CAN'T GET
A FULL NIGHT'S REST, WE NAP.
THAT'S WHY WE BUILT NAPWELL,
THE WORLD'S FIRST NAPPING MASK.
WE WANT TO HELP YOU
NAPTIMIZE.
"NAPTIMIZING" MEANS
FALLING ASLEEP GENTLY
AND WAKING UP
FEELING REFRESHED.
YOU SEE,
WHEN YOU SLEEP,
YOUR BODY CYCLES
THROUGH DIFFERENT STAGES.
IF YOU'RE AWOKEN ABRUPTLY
IN A DEEP STAGE OF SLEEP,
YOU GET
A NASTY HEADACHE.
SCIENTISTS CALL THIS FEELING
SLEEP INERTIA,
AND PERHAPS
YOU'VE FELT IT YOURSELF.
IT'S THAT GROGGY FEELING
THAT JUST RUINS
YOUR ENTIRE DAY'S PRODUCTIVITY.
THE NAPWELL
HELPS YOU NAPTIMIZE
BY USING LIGHTS
TO MIMIC A SUNRISE
AND WAKE YOU GRADUALLY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS SET THE TIMER,
AND 10 MINUTES BEFORE
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO WAKE UP,
THE MASK GETS BRIGHTER,
AND IT PREVENTS
THOSE NASTY HEADACHES.
SLEEP IS VITAL
TO A PERSON'S WELL-BEING,
BUT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
DON'T GET ENOUGH SLEEP.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN HELP
THESE PEOPLE ONE NAP AT A TIME.
SO, WHO WANTS TO JOIN US
AND HELP THE WORLD NAP WELL?
OKAY, WE HAVE
TWO SPECIAL PROTOTYPES
THAT WE WOULD
LOVE YOU TO TRY.
WHO WANTS
TO GIVE IT A SHOT?
THIS IS NOT FOR SLEEPING
AT NIGHT -- ONLY NAPPING?
IT CAN BE USED
FOR SLEEPING AT NIGHT.
HERE --
I'M GONNA HAVE ROBERT DO IT.
SO, THIS GOES
OVER YOUR NOSE?
OVER YOUR NOSE LIKE --
OVER YOUR NOSE.
THAT GOES
ON TOP OF YOUR NOSE.
Greiner:
THE LIGHTS ARE OFF NORMALLY.
Joglekar: CORRECT.
BUT YOU SET IT SO THAT
IF YOU'RE GONNA TAKE A NAP --
QUIET, LORI.
I'M SLEEPING.
[ LAUGHS ]
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE A NAP
FOR 20 MINUTES,
THEN AT THE LAST COUPLE
OF MINUTES,
THE LIGHTS START TO GO
GRADUALLY.
SO,
THE LAST 10 MINUTES.
I MEAN, LOOK,
WE'VE ALL TAKEN POWER NAPS.
SURE.
I'VE NEVER HAD
A BAD POWER NAP.
I HAVE.
YOU HAVE? SERIOUSLY?
NO, IF I NAP
IN THE AFTERNOON...
IT MEANS YOU'RE OLD.
...I WAKE UP
FEELING CRABBY.
IT DOES NOT MAKE ME
FEEL BETTER.
SO, WHEN YOU SLEEP,
YOUR BODY CYCLES.
IF YOU WAKE UP
IN STAGE 3 AND 4,
THAT'S WHEN YOU GET
THESE GROGGY HEADACHES.
SO, JUSTIN,
THAT'S COMMON SCIENCE, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THEY TEACH YOU ALL THIS
REM SLEEP AND EVERYTHING.
YOU GOT TO GET
CERTAIN CYCLES OF SLEEP.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHERE ARE YOU
WITH THE COMPANY?
ARE YOU A SCIENTIST?
ARE YOU A DOCTOR?
SO, JUSTIN AND I ACTUALLY MET
AT A 7th GRADE SUMMER CAMP.
AT LEAST, WE LIKE
TO CALL IT SUMMER CAMP.
REALLY,
WE MET AT NERD CAMP.
HE WAS LEARNING MEDICINE,
AND I WAS LEARNING PASCAL,
AN OLD
COMPUTER-PROGRAMING LANGUAGE.
AND, SO, THE IDEA WAS
THAT WE'D ALWAYS GO
TO COLLEGE TOGETHER,
BUT HE ENDED UP
GOING TO M.I.T.,
AND I ENDED UP GOING
TO THE WEST COAST, TO STANFORD.
Lee: SO I DID MY UNDERGRAD
AT M.I.T.,
DOUBLED
IN PHYSICS AND BIOLOGY.
WOW.
DID MY MASTER'S THERE
ALSO,
BUT IN
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING.
SO RIGHT NOW, THOUGH,
I AM A PhD STUDENT
IN A JOINT M.I.T./HARVARD
MEDICAL SCHOOL PROGRAM
FOR MEDICAL ENGINEERING
AND MEDICAL PHYSICS.
OH, WOW.
AND I JUST WRAPPED UP
A PROJECT
FUNDED BY
THE GATES FOUNDATION
TO DEVELOP DRONES
FOR VACCINE DELIVERY IN AFRICA.
SO, YOU HAVE NO CREDIBILITY,
IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
John:
AND YOU CAME UP WITH THIS?
THAT'S
REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
IT IS.
I MEAN,
THAT'S REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
HOW DID YOU GO FROM ALL OF THAT
TO MAKING A MASK?
WE SEE STARTUPS AS SORT OF
A SERIES OF TESTS OF HYPOTHESES.
THE FIRST HYPOTHESIS WAS...
WELL SAID.
...CAN WE MAKE
A PHYSICAL PRODUCT?
AND SO
WE BUILT THE PROTOTYPE.
THE SECOND TEST WAS,
"COULD WE GET PEOPLE
WE DIDN'T KNOW
TO BUY THE PRODUCT?"
THAT'S WHY WE DID
THE CROWDFUNDING CAMPAIGN.
SO, OUR GOAL FOR THAT
WAS $30,000.
WE ENDED UP SELLING
ABOUT $52,000 WORTH OF PRODUCT.
WHAT WERE YOU SELLING
PER UNIT?
WE ACTUALLY USED CROWDFUNDING
TO TEST DIFFERENT PRICES.
WE SOLD IT
FROM $50 TO $150.
Greiner:
I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHAT TYPE OF TESTING
DID YOU DO
TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THIS WORKS?
FROM THE KICKSTARTER FUNDING
ITSELF,
THOSE BACKERS
HAVE BEEN OUR EARLY TESTERS.
SO YOU SENT THEM MASKS.
WE DELIVERED ABOUT 100 MASKS
TO OUR EARLY CUSTOMERS.
AND THEY REPORTED
BACK TO YOU.
CORRECT.
THEY DOCUMENTED
HOW THEY FELT EVERY DAY.
I SLEEP ON AVERAGE
THREE, FOUR HOURS A NIGHT.
I'M ALWAYS TIRED.
REALLY?
ISN'T THE PROBLEM THAT
MOST PEOPLE CAN'T GET TO SLEEP?
THE BASIC PROBLEM IS PEOPLE'S
SLEEPING HABITS IN GENERAL.
SO, WHEN WE WERE FIGURING OUT
HOW WE MIGHT SOLVE THAT PROBLEM,
WE DEBATED
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
THE MASK
WASN'T THE FIRST ONE.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT PILLOWS,
WE THOUGHT ABOUT BLANKETS.
SO WE THINK
THERE'S A GAP
IN THE MARKET
FOR WEARABLE TECHNOLOGY.
IF YOU WALKED INTO ANY V.C.
IN THE VALLEY
WITH YOUR BACKGROUND,
IF YOU JUST SNEEZE
AND CALL IT A STARTUP,
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO RAISE $250,000 TO $300,000.
SO WHY
HAVEN'T YOU DONE THAT?
FOR ME, LIKE,
I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT BEFORE.
I'M NEW TO THE -- I'M REALLY NEW
TO THE STARTUP WORLD.
SO, WE REALLY WANTED
TO VALIDATE TO OURSELVES
THAT THIS WAS
A VIABLE PRODUCT.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT,
"WELL, WE JUST DECIDED
"TO SKIP THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO GRAB SOMEBODY'S MONEY
"TO COME ON 'SHARK TANK'
AND NEGOTIATE A VALUATION
BECAUSE WE'RE DYING
TO HAVE ONE OF THESE SHARKS."
YOU GUYS,
YOU GUYS, WAIT.
I'M NOT BUYING IT, GUYS.
I'M NOT BUYING IT.
LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION, OKAY?
John:
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I'M OUT, GUYS.
FOR ME, THE BASICS --
I'M OUT.
OKAY, SO MARK'S OUT.
SO, LET ME
ASK A QUESTION.
LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT THIS,
ALL RIGHT?
I HAVE
A DIFFERENT PROBLEM.
YOU'VE NEVER ACTUALLY
BROUGHT TO MARKET
A CONSUMER GOOD, PRODUCT,
OR COMPANY, OKAY?
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO, BETWEEN YOUR PROTOTYPE
AND A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
THAT'S SHIPPING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS' WORTH OF PRODUCT,
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF HURT
THAT HAPPENS,
AND ONE OF THEM
IS THE MARKETING ASPECT OF THIS,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS TO MOST PEOPLE
THAT SEE IT ON THE SHELF
AS A SLEEP MASK THAT THEY'RE
USED TO PAYING $1.99 FOR.
THAT IS A TASK FROM HELL.
IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY TOUGH.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
TO ME, I THINK PEOPLE HAVE
TROUBLE GOING TO SLEEP.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM WAKING UP.
THERE'S A MILLION DEVICES
OUT THERE TO WAKE UP.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THE PATH TO SUCCESS
IS NEVER IN A STRAIGHT LINE.
YOU GUYS ARE SUPERSMART GUYS.
YOU SHOULD BE EXTREMELY PROUD.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
ALL OF THAT BACKGROUND
AND EDUCATION
AND ALL THAT SUFFERING THAT
YOUR PARENTS PUT YOU THROUGH
TO MAKING A SLEEP MASK.
IT'S JUST TOO CHALLENGING.
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
APPRECIATE IT.
ALL RIGHT,
WHO'S LEFT?
ME. WELL, UM...
...I'M A GUY WHO BELIEVES YOU
SHOULD HAVE PROOF OF CONCEPT,
THEN YOU BUILD A BUSINESS
AND PROVE THAT THE MODEL WORKS.
IT'S JUST TOO EARLY.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Joglekar: OKAY.
Herjavec:
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
CONGRATS.
I LIKE THEIR ONESIES.
Jonglekur:
I THINK THEY FELT LIKE WE WERE
A PRODUCT IN SEARCH OF A MARKET,
BUT WHAT
THEY DIDN'T REALIZE,
AND WHAT WE PROBABLY
DID A POOR JOB OF EXPLAINING,
IS THAT THE DEMAND
FOR THIS PRODUCT
AND THE MARKET
ARE ENORMOUS,
AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SO EXCITED ABOUT IT.
MY NAME IS KRISTINA GUERRERO,
AND I LIVE IN THE SMALL TOWN
OF LA PINE, OREGON,
WITH MY HUSBAND, BRANDON,
AND OUR TWO CANINE SIDEKICKS,
DUNKAN AND ODIN.
Guerrero: GOOD BOY!
WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER,
THINGS GOT PRETTY ROCKY AT HOME,
SO WHEN I WAS 17, I APPLIED
TO THE AIR FORCE ACADEMY,
AND IT WAS THE BEST DECISION
I EVER MADE.
I GRADUATED AS A LIEUTENANT
AND WENT ON TO FLY C-130s
IN SUPPORT OF THREE DEPLOYMENTS.
AFTER THE AIR FORCE,
I DECIDED TO FOLLOW MY PASSIONS.
IT BASICALLY BROUGHT ME
TO THE BACKCOUNTRY OF OREGON.
I'M A MOUNTAIN GIRL, AND I LOVE
HANGING OUT WITH MY DOGS.
MY DOGS AND I WERE
AT THE TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN
WHEN I REALIZED
I DIDN'T PACK ENOUGH SUPPLIES.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT,
AND I REALIZED
THERE'S A REALLY SIMPLE SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM.
SO WE GOT HOME, AND I STARTED
FORMULATING MY PRODUCT
AND OUR BUSINESS
HAS BEEN GROWING EVER SINCE.
GREAT. LET ME JUST GET DOWN
YOUR PHONE NUMBER.
SINCE I'VE STARTED
THIS BUSINESS,
IT'S BEEN AN UPHILL BATTLE.
I'VE BEEN MAKING
A LOT OF MISTAKES,
AND I PUT MY SAVINGS
ON THE LINE.
I DEFINITELY NEED SOMEONE
WITH MORE BUSINESS SAVVY
TO HELP MY COMPANY EVOLVE,
AND I HOPE THAT THE SHARKS
CAN SEE HOW DETERMINED I AM
TO MAKE THIS BUSINESS
SUCCESSFUL.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HI.
MY NAME IS KRISTINA GUERRERO,
AND THIS IS ODIN,
AND WE'RE OUT HERE TODAY
FROM LA PINE, OREGON,
ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR A 20% STAKE
INTO OUR COMPANY, TurboPUP.
LIKE A LOT OF DOG OWNERS,
MY DOGS AREN'T JUST MY PETS.
THEY'RE MY SIDEKICKS.
WHETHER I'M SKIING,
HIKING, TRAVELING --
EVEN SWIMMING WITH SHARKS --
CHANCES ARE MY DOG IS WITH ME.
BUT WHAT WASN'T FUN WAS
PACKING BULKY BAGS OF DOG FOOD,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WEIGHT,
QUALITY, AND SIZE MATTER.
SO I CREATED TurboPUP --
COMPLETE CANINE MEAL BARS.
TurboPUP BARS ARE MADE
WITH 100% AMERICAN-SOURCED,
HUMAN-GRADE, ALL-NATURAL,
GRAIN-FREE INGREDIENTS.
THEY'RE SAFE
ON SENSITIVE STOMACHS
AND INTERCHANGEABLE
WITH REGULAR DOG FOOD.
WHEN I'M OUT IN THE BACKCOUNTRY
OR TRAVELING,
I'M MAKING SURE
I HAVE THE FUEL I NEED.
WOW.
SO I DESIGNED TurboPUP BARS
SPECIFICALLY TO SUSTAIN
DOGS' ENERGY LEVELS...
[ LAUGHS ]
...AND, OF COURSE,
FUEL ALL DOGKIND.
IF YOU GUYS
WANT TO CHECK OUT THE BARS,
I CAN BRING THEM OVER
AND YOU CAN GIVE SOME TO ODIN.
YEAH.
LET'S DO THAT.
Greiner:
I WOULD LOVE THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
IS THIS EDIBLE
FOR HUMANS, TOO?
'CAUSE YOU SAID
IT WAS HUMAN-GRADE.
IT'S HUMAN-GRADE INGREDIENTS,
'CAUSE WE JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE SUPER-PREMIUM.
SO, EACH ONE OF THOSE BARS
IS 250 CALORIES,
SO YOU CAN ONLY GIVE THEM
JUST A LITTLE PIECE.
HE REALLY LIKES IT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH.
YOU'RE IN TROUBLE NOW,
ROBERT.
THAT WHOLE BAR
WENT DOWN.
HE LIKES IT.
[ Laughing ]
OH, MY GOD.
COME ON, ODIN.
KEVIN, DO YOU WANT
TO GIVE HIM SOME?
I'LL PASS ON THAT,
KRISTINA.
OKAY.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
I'VE SEEN REAL HYENAS ON THE
RANGES OF ADDIS ABABA, ETHIOPIA,
AND LET ME TELL YOU,
THAT'S A HYENA, NOT A DOG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
KRISTINA,
WHAT MAKES THIS DIFFERENT
THAN THE OTHER 5,000 DOG TREATS
ON THE MARKET?
THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT MAKES IT DIFFERENT.
IT'S NOT A DOG TREAT.
WHAT IS IT?
A SANDWICH?
IT'S A COMPLETE MEAL.
SO, THAT'S 250 CALORIES.
AND BECAUSE
THE INGREDIENTS ARE SO PREMIUM,
YOU CAN JUST INTERCHANGE IT
WITH REGULAR DOG FOOD.
SO, HOW EXPENSIVE IS IT
IF IT'S SO PREMIUM?
SO, THE ONE-PACKS,
MSRP IS $2.99,
AND THE TWO-PACKS,
MSRP IS $4.99.
[ LAUGHTER ]
KRISTINA, IS IT LIKE AN
ENERGY BAR FOR DOGS, BASICALLY?
[ Laughing ] NO.
NO, BUT IT WAS DESIGNED
TO SUSTAIN ENERGY.
WELL, TELL ME,
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES SO FAR
AND WHERE
ARE YOU SELLING THEM?
SO, I STARTED SELLING
IN MAY 2013.
THESE WERE THE BARS
THAT I STARTED WITH.
I WAS MAKING THEM
OUT OF MY KITCHEN.
I WAS HAND-CUTTING
AND HAND-SEALING EACH BAR.
HOW MUCH DID YOU SELL?
WE HAD $4,000 IN SALES.
OKAY, AND THEN THIS YEAR,
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE'VE SOLD...$7,000.
KRISTINA,
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
MY BACKGROUND IS,
WHEN I WAS 17, I LEFT HOME,
WENT TO THE UNITED STATES
AIR FORCE ACADEMY.
GRADUATED FROM THE AIR FORCE
ACADEMY IN 2002.
GOOD FOR YOU.
WENT ON, BECAME A DISTINGUISHED
GRADUATE OF PILOT TRAINING,
FLEW C-130s
THROUGH THREE DEPLOYMENTS.
WOW.
RECEIVED TWO COMBAT AIR MEDALS
FOR THE DEPLOYMENTS
IN OPERATION ENDURING FREEDOM,
OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM.
THANK YOU.
I CAME HOME
FROM MY THIRD DEPLOYMENT.
HIM AND I
WERE BACKCOUNTRY SKIING.
WE WENT ABOUT 8 MILES
UP THE MOUNTAIN.
I HAD A BURRITO
OR SOME CHOCOLATE POWER BARS.
I, OF COURSE, DIDN'T THINK
OF PACKING DOG FOOD.
HE ATE THE BURRITO,
I ATE THE POWER BAR,
AND I HAD THIS LIGHT-BULB MOMENT
WHERE I JUST THOUGHT,
"WHY DON'T THEY HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS
"THAT'S A FULL MEAL --
NOT A TREAT -- FOR DOGS
FOR WHEN I GO OUT IN THE
BACKCOUNTRY OR WHEN I TRAVEL?"
WHO'S BUYING IT?
THIS IS
THE REALLY INTERESTING PART.
BECAUSE THE PET MARKET
IS SO SATURATED,
I DECIDED TO TRY
ANOTHER ROUTE.
I DECIDED TO START
APPROACHING OUTDOOR STORES.
AND HOW DID THEY RESPOND?
STOKED.
WHILE I WAS MAKING THE BARS
OUT OF MY KITCHEN,
TurboPUP BECAME
THE OFFICIAL DOG FOOD
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR SEARCH AND RESCUE.
GOOD FOR YOU.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
KRISTINA, ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT SKI SHOPS,
BIKE SHOPS, LIKE,
OUTDOOR PLACES?
YEP. YEP.
THAT'S SMART, BECAUSE
THERE'S A STRONG CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE TWO.
AND THERE'S NO COMPETITION
RIGHT NOW.
I GOT TO TELL YOU,
THAT'S VERY, VERY CLEVER.
THAT'S VERY SMART.
SO, RIGHT NOW,
I HAVE ABOUT 30 RETAILERS,
BUT THE CONVERSATION IS THERE
WITH MUCH BIGGER RETAILERS,
AND WE'RE ALSO TALKING TO
A PET STORE THAT HAS 55 STORES.
AND THIS IS JUST TO START.
AND THIS IS A ONE-WOMAN SHOW.
YOUR MOVE TO GO INTO
THE OUTDOOR STORES -- BRILLIANT.
THE ISSUE FOR ME IS,
WHEN I PARTNER WITH SOMEBODY,
I TRY TO GO ALL-IN
AND HELP AND LEARN.
I JUST DON'T KNOW YOUR AREA
AT ALL.
OKAY.
AND I JUST DON'T HAVE
THE TIME, IN REALITY,
TO DIG IN
AND LEARN IT FOR YOU.
I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT YOU DESERVE
A TON OF CREDIT.
YOU'RE MAKING
ALL THE RIGHT STEPS.
I'M WITH HIM --
YOU'RE DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT EVERY
BUSINESS THAT COMES OUT HERE
IS READY
FOR AN INVESTMENT.
RIGHT.
AND NOT EVERY BUSINESS
IS DESTINED TO BE
A BIG BUSINESS TODAY.
KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
GET THE SALES
FROM $7,000 TO $100,000,
AND THEN MAYBE
LOOK FOR AN INVESTMENT.
RIGHT --
AT THIS POINT, I'M OUT.
Greiner:
YOU KNOW, KRISTINA,
I AM NOT SURE
ABOUT THE MARKET FOR THIS.
YOU'RE KIND OF FORGING AHEAD
IN SOMETHING NEW.
YOU ARE MAKING A MEAL FOR A DOG,
AND YOU'RE LEARNING.
DO PEOPLE NEED IT AND WANT IT
OR DON'T THEY?
SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD
TO SLOWLY GROW
AND KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND LEARNING HOW BIG THE MARKET
IS FOR THIS STEP BY STEP.
AND THEN YOU GROW
IN A SMART WAY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
THEN THERE WAS TWO.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THEN
THERE IS TWO.
OKAY, I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THIS PITCH.
$7,000 IN THE
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR
PET-FOOD MARKET
IS TURBO-POOP ON A STICK.
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT
AND MAKE IT MORE COMPELLING.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GONNA GET
AN INVESTMENT. I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I'M ON THE FENCE, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE $100,000 FOR 20%,
THAT VALUES YOUR COMPANY
AT $500,000.
THE PROBLEM IS,
YOU'RE ASKING SO MUCH,
I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
SO MUCH.
WHAT WOULD YOU ASK,
AS FAR AS YOUR EQUITY?
THE GAMBLE
THAT I WOULD TAKE WITH YOU IS,
BECAUSE OF YOUR TOURS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE,
YOU MUST BE DISCIPLINED.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU DON'T SLEEP,
JUST LIKE ME.
WELL,
THEY SAY THAT THE TURBO
IS BECAUSE I HAVE TWO MODES --
TURBO OR OFF.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'LL GO $100,000
FOR 40%.
THE COMPANY
ISN'T WORTH $500,000.
YEAH, BUT THE COMPANY'S SCALING
FAIRLY QUICKLY WITH NO HELP.
WOULD YOU DO 30%?
NO, IT'S NOT WORTH IT
FOR ME.
I'M SORRY.
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL IT
THE SHARK TANK.
THEY DO.
THAT'S WHY YOU DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH MEAT ON THE BONE
TO PROVE ITS VALUE.
NOW YOU'RE PAYING
THE PRICE.
KRISTINA, HE'S OFFERING YOU
$100,000 FOR 40%.
DO YOU REALLY WANT
TO COUNTER AT 30%?
35%?
IS THAT FAIR?
35% -- YOU GOT IT.
YES!
DONE? ALL RIGHT.
Cuban: THERE YOU GO.
IT'S A DEAL.
Greiner: THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
HYENA, BITE HIM.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
Greiner: CONGRATULATIONS.
KRISTINA,
CAN I HAVE THE DOG?
CONGRATULATIONS, KRISTINA.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
THAT WAS A MERCY FINANCE.
I THINK SHE GOT IT ALL TOGETHER
TO THIS POINT,
AND A WOMAN WHO DID
THREE TOURS FOR OUR COUNTRY
IS NOT GONNA GO TO SLEEP.
THERE IS NO DOUBT
SHE'S THE REAL DEAL.
Guerrero: I AM SO ECSTATIC
THAT DAYMOND TOOK TurboPUP ON.
I'M JUST SO GRATEFUL
THAT HE SEES THE VISION.
I'M JUST SO EXCITED.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A BUSINESS
DESIGNED FOR THE PERFECT FIT.
HELLO, SHARKS!
YOU'RE ALL LOOKING
MIGHTY DAPPER TODAY!
MY NAME IS JOE CHAY
FROM COLUMBUS, OHIO,
AND I'M SEEKING $360,000
FOR A 6% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY GROWING CUSTOM-CLOTHING
LABEL, BELLO VERDE.
BELLO VERDE IS THE ULTIMATE
LUXURY SUITING EXPERIENCE.
OUR MASTER TAILORS HAVE YEARS OF
KNOWLEDGE IN SUIT MANUFACTURING.
EACH OF OUR GARMENTS COMES WITH
FULL CANVAS CONSTRUCTION,
FUNCTIONAL BUTTONHOLES
ON EVERY SLEEVE,
HANDPICKED STITCHING
ON EVERY SINGLE SEAM,
AND A WEALTH
OF OTHER CUSTOM OPTIONS.
UH-HUH.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE CARRY THOUSANDS OF FABRICS
FROM THE GREATEST MILLS
ON THE WORLD,
AND WE TAKE UP TO 30
MEASUREMENTS ON YOUR BODY
SO IT FITS PERFECT
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
WHETHER YOU'RE
A 5'6" UFC SUPERSTAR...
Herjavec:
[ Chuckling ] HEY!
URIJAH!
...OR A 6'1" SUPERMAN,
BELLO VERDE WILL MAKE SURE
IT FITS YOU RIGHT.
CAN IT GET ANY BETTER?!
[ LAUGHTER ]
ACTUALLY, IT CAN.
OUR CLOTHING IS CUSTOM-MADE.
SHARKS, WE ARE ON THE VERGE --
THE PRECIPICE --
OF MONUMENTAL GROWTH.
YOU HAVE THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE PART OF THAT.
NOW, SHARKS, WHO WANTS
TO LOOK SHARP WITH US?
JOE, TELL US
ABOUT THE GUYS BEHIND YOU.
ABSOLUTELY.
SO, THIS IS URIJAH FABER.
URIJAH IS A UFC SUPERSTAR.
SUPERSTAR!
SUPERSTAR.
HE WAS THE W.E.C. CHAMPION
OF THE WORLD,
AND HE'S ALSO BEEN
A HUGE INFLUENCE ON MY LIFE
AND A BIG MENTOR FOR ME,
AS WELL.
DEAN HAS BEEN
A GREAT FRIEND
AND CUSTOMER OF OUR CLOTHING
FOR YEARS,
AND HE JUST LOOKS GREAT
IN IT,
AND WHO BETTER THAN SUPERMAN,
DEAN CAIN?
WHAT DOES
"BELLO VERDE" MEAN?
IT MEANS "BEAUTIFUL GREEN"
IN ITALIAN.
I CAME UP WITH THE NAME
AFTER WORKING AT A PREVIOUS
COMPANY CALLED ASTOR & BLACK.
HAVE YOU GUYS HEARD
OF ASTOR & BLACK?
I HAVE.
OKAY, SO, ASTOR & BLACK
WAS A COMPANY
THAT I WORKED FOR
FOR 10 YEARS.
I BASICALLY DID EVERYTHING THERE
FROM SALES TO MANAGEMENT.
I HAVEN'T HEARD
OF THAT BRAND.
WERE THEY
A HIGH-END-SUIT BRAND?
OH, YEAH. THEY DO
CUSTOM CLOTHING. AND I KNOW --
PURELY CUSTOM?
PURELY CUSTOM.
THEY WERE DOING
$42 MILLION IN SALES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR COMPANY,
BECAUSE I'M INTERESTED IN YOU.
SO, LET'S TALK
ABOUT MY COMPANY.
DEAN, URIJAH,
WHY DON'T YOU GO SHOW THEM --
GO OVER THERE
AND SHOW THEM --
I WANT TO KNOW
WHY DEAN WEARS THE CLOTHES.
Cain: OKAY,
SO, I DON'T LIKE TO SHOP.
I DON'T LIKE TO GO IN.
I DON'T WANT TO TRY TO FIND
THINGS OFF THE RACK.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
I'M A FOOTBALL PLAYER
ORIGINALLY.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT BUILD.
I WANT A SUIT THAT FITS ME,
THAT I LIKE,
THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
GO RUN AROUND AND LOOK FOR.
I WANT TO KNOW --
IF I'M NOT SO FASHION-FORWARD,
I WANT MY SALESPERSON
TO BE ABLE TO TELL ME,
"HEY, LOOK,
THIS IS WHAT'S IN NOW."
SO, JOE BASICALLY
IS ALSO KIND OF YOUR STYLIST.
YOU TRUST HIM?
YES.
DO YOU GO TO SOMEONE'S HOME --
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU SAID,
"I DON'T EVEN LIKE
GOING TO THE STORE."
DO YOU COME IN --
YEAH, THE WAY
THE ASTOR & BLACK MODEL WORKS,
ALL THEIR SALES
WERE DIRECT AGENT --
FORGET THEIR MODEL.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR MODEL.
WELL, IT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT.
IT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT.
I WOULDN'T BE BORING YOU
WITH THE OLD-NEWS COMPANY
IF IT WASN'T IMPORTANT
TO MY STORY.
I PROMISE YOU
THERE'S SOMETHING GOOD.
Greiner:
ALL RIGHT, TELL US.
OKAY, GET INTO IT.
GET INTO IT.
OKAY, SO, THINGS WERE TOUGH
WHEN I LEFT.
WHEN I LEFT, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS GONNA DO.
I DECIDED
TO OPEN UP BELLO VERDE.
I WAS VERY FORTUNATE --
ASTOR & BLACK WENT UNDER,
AND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING
WHICH WOULD PUT ME
AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
WHAT?
WHAT DID YOU DO?
DEAN, URIJAH,
SHOW THEM WHAT WE GOT!
BOOM!
I BOUGHT THAT COMPANY.
SO I OWN BOTH --
WHAT DID YOU
BUY IT FOR?
I BOUGHT IT FOR $405,000.
WHAT OTHER ASSETS DID YOU GET
FOR THE $405,000?
I GOT OVER $1 MILLION
IN BELTS, SHOES,
GOT IT, GOT IT.
SWEATERS, JEANS, TIES.
HOW MUCH CASH
ARE YOU GONNA MAKE?
SO, $1 MILLION
IN INVENTORY AND BELTS.
YES.
WHAT ELSE?
OVER $1 MILLION INVENTORY.
WE GOT A BACK-END WEB SYSTEM
THAT'S WORTH
OVER 3/4 OF $1 MILLION.
IT TIES OUR FACTORIES
TO OUR SALES AGENTS.
IT'S A CUSTOM SERVICE,
SO IF DEAN WANTS
SOMEBODY TO COME TO HIS HOME,
WHATEVER THE REP IS
IN THAT REGION
GOES TO HIS HOME
AND FITS HIM.
THAT IS WHAT ASTOR & BLACK
OF THE PAST DID.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT IDEA.
WHAT'S YOUR IDEA?
THAT'S GONNA BE ONE OF FOUR
OF MY REVENUE STREAMS.
WHAT IS YOUR IDEA?
WHAT'S YOUR IDEA?
THE OTHER THREE
REVENUE STREAMS --
THE FIRST ONE
IS GOING TO BE ONLINE SALES.
WE'VE ALREADY DEVELOPED
AND LAUNCHED AN ONLINE STORE
FOR ACCESSORIES -- SHOES, BELTS,
SWEATERS, TIES, ALL THE ABOVE.
NO, I GOT IT.
WHAT'S THE OTHER MODEL?
THE OTHER MODEL
IS THERE ARE COMPANIES OUT THERE
THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
ALGORITHMS.
THESE ALGORITHMS CAN TAKE
BASIC QUESTIONS FROM A CONSUMER
AND SPIT OUT AND PRINT OUT
A SET OF MEASUREMENTS.
YEAH, ONE OF MY COMPANIES
IS FASHION METRIC,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY DO.
AND I'VE SPOKEN TO THE C.E.O.
AND C.O.O. OF FASHION METRIC...
JOE, IS IT TRUE --
...ABOUT INCORPORATING
THAT TECHNOLOGY...
THEY WILL HELP YOU.
JOE, THROW ME
A BONE HERE.
I ONLY HAVE ONE SIMPLE QUESTION,
VERY IMPORTANT.
YES.
THIS COMPANY THAT YOU BOUGHT
FOR $405,000 --
HOW MUCH CASH
WILL IT MAKE THIS YEAR?
HOW MUCH CASH DO YOU THINK
IT'LL MAKE THIS YEAR?
YOU MEAN
I HAVE TO ANSWER THAT?
WHAT,
ARE YOU AN IDIOT?
I WAS GONNA ASK YOUR QUESTION
FOR YOU.
YOU TELL ME.
WHAT'S THE MATTER WITH YOU?
NO, HE JUST WANTS TO TAKE
YOU OUT BEHIND THE BARN
AND SHOOT YOU. THAT'S ALL.
I'M ASKING YOU
AS AN INVESTOR,
AND YOU'RE TELLING ME
I SHOULD KNOW?
NO, NO,
I'M JUST ASKING --
JOE,
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
MY SALES THIS YEAR
WILL BE $2 MILLION.
ON THE $2 MILLION,
WE'LL NET OVER $500,000.
AND, SO, WHAT'S THE COST
OF AN AVERAGE SUIT?
WE TOP OUT IN
THE $2,500-TO-$3,000 SUIT RANGE,
BUT OUR
BREAD-AND-BUTTER BUSINESS
IS THAT
$1,000-TO-$1,500 SUIT.
ASTOR & BLACK
DEFINITELY IS RECOGNIZABLE.
WHY NOW TWO NAMES?
THE REASON WHY IT'S GREAT
THAT WE HAVE TWO
IS BECAUSE
NOW WE CAN POSITION THEM --
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
HOLD ON. LET ME FINISH.
LET ME FINISH TELLING YOU
WHAT I WANT TO DO.
YEAH, YOU CAN,
BUT IT'S A HEADACHE.
LET ME TELL YOU MY PLAN.
TWO BRANDS.
THE FIRST ONE IS RETAIL.
ASTOR & BLACK NEVER PUT IN
A SINGLE DOLLAR OF SALES
FOR RETAIL.
YOU WANT TO BE IN RETAIL?
Herjavec: SO,
YOU'RE GONNA GO RETAIL, JOE?
OOH.
I'M GOING TO PERHAPS
GIVE IT THE CONSIDERATION,
WITH ONE OF YOUR HELP.
THE OTHER TWO --
WHOLESALE.
I'M GONNA OPEN UP
A WHOLESALE STREAM
TO SELL THIS PRODUCT
TO OTHER PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS.
JOE, I ACTUALLY USE
ONE OF YOUR COMPETITORS.
THAT'S WHY
I LOOK SO FABULOUS.
EVERYTHING IS MADE
BY MY TAILOR.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHO YOU USE.
OKAY,
SO, HERE'S THE PROBLEM
THAT I LOOK AT AS A DISCIPLINED
FINANCIAL INVESTOR.
SURE.
YOU'VE COME IN HERE AND SAID,
"I'LL MAKE $500,000,"
AND YET YOU PRICED IT
AT 12 TIMES.
SURE.
I'M JUST LOOKING
AT YOUR VALUATION
AND SAYING TO MYSELF,
"YOU'RE SO FAR FROM REALITY,"
AND FOR THAT REASON,
JUST SO I CAN MAKE IT EASY
FOR DAYMOND TO BEAT YOU
WITH A STICK IN A MINUTE,
I'M OUT.
OKAY. NO PROBLEM.
AND I APPRECIATE IT, KEVIN.
I REALLY DO.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE MEN'S CUSTOM-SUIT BUSINESS.
SO I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE IT, LORI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOE,
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
THERE ARE GUYS LIKE KEVIN
WHO LOVE CUSTOM SUITS,
THAT HAVE FUNNY BODIES,
WEIRD SHAPES.
ADONIS BODIES
REQUIRE A TAILOR.
I CAN THROW A DART
AND I CAN FIND IN TORONTO,
NEW YORK, L.A., BOSTON
HUNDREDS
OF CUSTOM TAILORS.
IT IS REALLY
A BRANDING EXERCISE.
I ALSO FIND THE DUAL-NAME
STRATEGY CONFUSING.
I THINK,
WHEN YOU'RE SMALL,
YOU GOT TO BE REALLY
LASER-LIKE FOCUSED, RIGHT?
SURE.
I THINK GOING TO MARKET
WITH TWO BRANDS LIKE THIS,
I MEAN,
IT'S JUST CONFUSING.
I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
YOU'VE GOT
MARK AND DAYMOND LEFT.
TWO SHARKS LEFT.
WHEN I FIRST SOLD
broadcast.com
AND I WAS WORTH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
AND I FIGURED, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA GO DRESS UP,"
AND SO I WENT
TO OUR LOCAL CUSTOM GUY,
AND "OKAY,
LET'S DO IT UP RIGHT."
SO, LITERALLY,
I SPENT $95,000
AND GOT, LIKE, 19 SUITS,
AND I THOUGHT --
COME ON!
YOU NEVER
WORE THEM ONCE.
I'VE WORN THREE OF THEM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AS FAR AS YOUR STRATEGY,
I THINK
YOU'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
YOU WERE ABLE TO BUY $1 MILLION
IN INVENTORY FOR $400,000,
GET THE BACK OFFICE,
GET THE ONLINE.
THE REAL ISSUE
IS THAT THE WAY YOU'VE PRICED IT
AT A $6 MILLION VALUATION,
YOU LITERALLY
HAVE TO GROW 10 TIMES
BEFORE YOU CAN
REALLY BE A PLAYER
FOR ME TO GET A RETURN
ON MY INVESTMENT.
WELL, WHAT WOULD YOU THINK
IS MORE FAIR OF A NUMBER?
REGARDLESS,
YOU STILL HAVE TO GROW
TO GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE YOU ARE REALLY --
WE'RE GONNA GROW.
WE'RE DOUBLING NEXT YEAR.
I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO DO --
JOE. JOE.
JOE! SHH!
WE KNOW.
YOU'RE A GOOD SALESPERSON.
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB.
AND YOU'RE GONNA GO FAR
WITH THIS COMPANY.
BUT AS AN INVESTOR,
I DON'T THINK THE REWARD
IS THERE RELATIVE TO THE RISK.
I'M OUT.
FAIR ENOUGH.
OKAY, JOE, GET FOCUSED.
THERE'S ONLY ONE SHARK LEFT.
OKAY, BIG "D,"
WHATCHA GONNA DO?
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER,
AND IT'S GONNA BE SO SWEET,
IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU A CAVITY.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER,
AND IT'S GONNA BE SO SWEET,
IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU A CAVITY.
NOW...
[ LAUGHTER ]
I BET IT'S GONNA BE
VERY PAINFUL.
OH.
YOU ASKED FOR $360,000
FOR 6%.
I WILL GIVE YOU $360,000
FOR 33%.
[ LAUGHS ]
OHHHHH!
O'Leary:
OKAY, MR. LEPRECHAUN.
YOU'VE JUST BEEN OFFERED
A POT OF GOLD.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
Chay: THAT IS A NUMBER
THAT IS SO FAR OFF
FROM WHAT I WOULD ACCEPT
THAT IT'S PROBABLY
NOT EVEN A GOOD IDEA
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT.
MAKE A COUNTER.
I MEAN, MY COUNTEROFFER
WOULD BE $360,000 FOR 7%.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GUY'S GOT
A LOT OF ROOM TO MOVE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO COUNTER WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S SOMEWHERE
REALISTIC...
MY BOTTOM LINE
IS $360,000 --
AND IF I DID THIS,
BY THE WAY,
TELL US.
IT WOULD BE INSULTING
TO THE OTHER --
GET IT OUT!
WHAT IS IT?!
$360,000
FOR 8% OF THE COMPANY.
THAT IS MY BOTTOM LINE.
IT'S GONNA GET REALLY UGLY
IN A MINUTE.
NO, I DON'T THINK IT IS.
IT IS. YEAH.
Herjavec:
IT'S HILARIOUS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
DAYMOND?
I WILL GIVE YOU
$360,000 --
'CAUSE I THINK YOU JUST
WENT CRAZY FOR A SECOND --
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
$360,000...
...FOR 25%.
LISTEN --
AND NOW I'M BENDING
A LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
LISTEN,
I APPRECIATE THE BEND.
AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE --
I APPRECIATE THE BEND.
I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS ARE MISSING OUT
ON A GIANT OPPORTUNITY.
I KNOW
YOU GUYS DON'T NEED IT.
WELL, FRANKLY, YOU'RE MISSING
OUT ON A GIANT OPPORTUNITY, TOO.
YEAH, BUT I CAN'T GIVE AWAY
1/4 OF A BUSINESS
THAT I KNOW
IS WORTH AS MUCH AS I --
NO, I GET IT,
BUT WHY DON'T YOU COUNTER HIM
WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE REASONABLE?
I AM COUNTERING HIM
WITH SOMETHING
THAT I THINK
IS MORE REASONABLE.
COME TO YOUR SENSES,
OR WE'RE GONNA BE KICKING YOU
OUT OF HERE IN A SECOND.
SO, ARE YOU DECLINING
MY OFFER?
AT THAT LEVEL, REGRETFULLY,
I HAVE TO DECLINE.
OKAY.
I'M NOT COUNTERING.
JOE, SAYONARA.
I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU GUYS' TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AND SEE YOU
ON THE ROAD TO $100 MILLION.
O'Leary: NEVER IN THE HISTORY
OF "SHARK TANK"
WHAT AN IDIOT.
HAVE I HEARD SOMEBODY
TALK SO MUCH AND SAY SO LITTLE.
Chay: I THOUGHT THE SHARKS
COULD BE STRATEGIC INVESTORS,
BUT ULTIMATELY,
IF THEY FAIL TO SEE THE VISION
OR GIVE PROPER VALUATION
TO MY BUSINESS,
THEY'RE NOT THE RIGHT TYPE
OF PARTNER FOR ME.